people of the internet retroreckons who
are here and welcome back to harry
potter and the chamber of secrets guys
we are getting it started
straight away with a wizard card see
what i did is i went off stream and i
collected all those birdie bop beans
because i know they can get
a little bit boring when you watch
somebody collect hundreds of beans and
they get hit by a ghost and you lose
some beans and then you get hit by a
random book flying at you and you lose
some beans so
i went off stream got all the way up to
100 and then i just
bought this from the weasley so we have
edgar
stroger inventor of the sneaker scope
to 1798 and i got 100
beans so i should be able to buy one
more let's go ahead and hop over here
let's see who we got here
beatrix blocks every flavor oh it's only
30.
yeah let's buy that yeah i didn't
realize they were only 30. i thought
they were 50.
we're gonna be able to buy quite a few
of these things apparently one of her
readers was continuously sick
for three whole weeks
all right let's see what let's see what
beatrice is up to here
number eight or beatrix i'm sorry
1794-1810 author of the toadstool
tales a series of children's books
wait what author of the toadstool tales
a series of children's books since
banned because they have been found to
cause
nausea and vomiting
wow that's just wrong feel free to spend
as long as you like it
i wonder if that's intentional or some
side effect that she did not intend
30 bucks every flavor beans all right
let's go ahead we might as well so
all right then we only missing one from
archibald
now there's a man who knew about
explosions so we need one more wizard
card from them
and we still need that wiggin well
potion file as well i thought about
buying it
number 29 archibald alderton
okay 1568-1623
famous for blowing up the hamlet of
little dropping
in hampshire whilst attempting to
magically mix a birthday cake
wow okay i love these things dude i
really do love the wizard cards all
right let's see who the last one is
how much is that thirty thirty bucks
thirty thirty word about beans i mean i
could go run around the castle and
probably get enough but you know what
i'm ready to end the day here we are
wrapping up uh
day three i believe this was oh
i just love the music man i just love
the music
waking up to a new day here in harry
potter and the chamber of secrets
folks if you're joining me for the first
time you should know i'm just a dad who
loves games and the stories they tell
and you are watching retrorec and tour
a let's play series for harry potter and
the chamber of secrets
we are getting ready to start day four
hello ron what class we got first today
it's
chance with flipwick army you on the
second floor
[Music]
okay charms with flitwick on the second
floor
so obviously everything is is kind of
sped up
in this game we're only on day four but
we've already actually
talked to uh malfoy while disguised as
crab and goyle um actually just harry
goes ron ron
doesn't go in the video game so here's
what we need to find in terms of the
lost and found board
uh neville has lost his toad trevor
answers to the name trevor property of
neville longbottom last seen near the
herbology greenhouses
if found please return to this notice
board all right
i gotta try and remember to make a run
out there to the herbology greenhouse
[Music]
okay i'm gonna go straight down there
i don't wanna i don't to stop and worry
about anything else i'm going to go
straight to charms
where i believe we should be learning
incendio which will be the last spell
so that's what i meant how the game's
kind of accelerated it's
obviously not the full calendar year
that they would have experienced at
hogwarts
oh here's ron right here let's go dude
incendio challenge chambers
called it good morning class today's
lesson will most hello
involve us in learning how to cast the
oppositely named
bluebell flames the proper incantation
from this charm
you will now see that a chord space has
been revealed in the war
beyond this is the incendio challenge mr
potter if you wouldn't mind coming
please mr potter he's always up for the
challenge on the other side of the crawl
space
once you've managed to collect it the
incendio charm will be yours
you must then return here to the
classroom do you understand
mr potter yep i do professor
well then off you jolly well go
off your jolly well go
all right there it is the foreboding
music
that music guys it feels like he's
walking down into the chamber of secrets
right now
all right what we got here what we got
what we got for the incendio
challenge chambers
hey what is that oh more of those guys
okay so for those dudes
i think we're gonna expelliarmus um and
i don't think we need
let's see we're probably not gonna need
aloha mora
for anything in here might need to use
abafords for something but
i know for sure we need expelliarmus for
those guys down there
and it looks like we've got flames on
both sides
uh so i do we just have to drop straight
down here i think we do
and you lose health man that's all right
so that makes me think that there was
another way
maybe
this guy gonna shoot if i try and run by
him
okay those don't do anything yet we need
incendio
okay you don't do anything with me just
walking by you all right how about you
okay i was thinking
something was gonna cause him to awaken
it's a little too close for comfort
[Music]
nice
you know what i kind of like it better
up close
now see that's just ridiculous just
completely not fair
yeah i want my beans back
all right out of my way gargoyle
okay so did he leave anything behind is
that a plate
no okay i'm just gonna go up here and
see where this leads
obviously we're supposed to go down that
way yeah i don't think we can even
make it through there right now i knew
it
i knew it i should not have done that
all right at least we got the beans back
though now we just need some health man
and would you look at the timing on the
pumpkin pasty
there's another one
dude i think this is the first time i've
seen these little statues look at these
things
look at this
what in the world this looks like
voldemort in the back of quirrell's head
does it not oh my goodness
not voldemort with his full body
voldemort when he's still in the back of
quirrell's head
that's that's what it looked like to me
maybe he made these and left them down
here
for somebody to find
okay can we make that jump yes we can
all right so we can't do anything
jump over here maybe you stand on this
yep okay but nothing's happening
we have to drop down and fight that guy
probably so right dude okay what am i
doing wrong here apparently you're not
supposed to fall
from this height but
i'm actually not sure you guys actually
not okay that i am sure obviously not
supposed to be
on the receiving end of that oh we were
supposed to go that way
where the gargoyle is because you can't
really defeat these uh
fire crabs
at least i don't think you can like can
i run up and
like mario you know when you flip them
on their back just then run up and
bash them give them a kick no another
fire crab over
there what is this
oh they open those gates
okay so when it triggers the cutscene
let's see if i still lose beans and get
hurt
no we didn't
oh i couldn't i couldn't uh
button just didn't respond quick enough
okay
see that's ridiculous man
i should probably quit worrying about
the beans
there we go
see he just shoots it at your feet every
now and then
i actually didn't know if that one was
gonna catch or not
all right not too bad not too bad
okay it opens up the way where that dude
is oh we do need to use avoforce
okay so let's switch off of lumos
and we'll throw abafords on y
and that bird should go and stand on one
of those platforms above
all right go ahead and flip him over we
are really pretty low on health right
now we don't want to take any hits here
got a guy right there all right
and yep the egg went over there
jump down here trigger cutscene don't
take any damage
and then hopefully we don't take any
damage against this guy
[Music]
gotta watch out for those
i see i don't even know how it would
move in time
[Music]
oh if he threw one at my feet i don't
know how it would move
oh i'm holding it too soon
here we go one more one more one more
harry
of course dude of course yep
i'm gonna collect the beans
oh he's really close
i don't know how many more hits we can
take guys one maybe okay that one's far
enough away
there we go too close for comfort man
way too close for comfort all right
we're gonna use avapors again
on this guy right here
send him up there and we still got to
watch out for the other fire crab
all right flip him over because i don't
know if we could
it's either one or two hits that we can
take
i really don't want to find out where i
get some health here
oh this is not good well there's this
spell book right there
but
is there any health in here please
no health oh man
[Music]
come on harry oh my goodness why is he
not grabbing it
really i have to be on this side come on
man
why can't he pick up the book from any
side really
all right incendio finally
all right so in cindy chapter 8
incendiary magic burns certain items
including webs there's often a
requirement for a spell of an incendiary
nature
especially when confronted by a spider's
web across a doorway or when a
distraction is required
for both of the above the incendio charm
can be used
otherwise known as the blue bell flames
or cold fire
incendio may also be used as a dueling
charm although care must be taken if the
opponent knows expelliarmus
see mastering wizard dueling above
where's mastering wizard dueling i want
to know about it
i want to know how to master wizard
dueling
okay we probably need to apply it though
let's go ahead and throw it on uh
let's throw it on x for now
although i really haven't used the
window at all in here have i
wait why is it purple then
you just told me how it's called
bluebell flames
one more i guess we did use a little bit
of flipindo to knock this little statue
up
oh so
oh man this is ridiculous
okay
okay you just need two that is really
weird that you just need to
wonder why that is come on give me
health again
the little voldemort statue gave me
health last time yeah there we go
come on one more yes that's what i'm
talking about how about a third
okay little baby voldemort is only so
kind
before he has to uh stop giving you
anything that you need
oh hold on hold on
yeah i'm gonna have to go down anyway
aren't i no no no
no harry i tried to stop him that time i
did
because i knew what was gonna happen
i totally knew what was gonna happen
nice
right now are those guys going to start
shooting flame
see nope not quite oh that opened up a
whole nother room
all right let's go ahead and do this
side as well
i actually thought it was just gonna
going to allow me to pass up top
i didn't expect it to open a completely
different room
oh and so did this one all right well
let us explore shall we
oh man we gotta hurry
okay that turns that one off
oh and it turns that one up wait so what
does the other one do
see he was already back up dude
or does that turn it back on
oh no there was another one okay now we
can hit that switch in there
that's just ridiculous
like i have no way of moving
well that little cut it's not even
really i guess it is a cut scene but
that's just not fair
all right now what is this side gonna do
wait so it did do
i'm so confused
did it not turn the one off in front of
the sh in front of the uh
i started to say shield in front of the
button
what is going on here okay we're gonna
okay buttons again
okay let's push a button okay it turned
the fire out
and then that fire stays on dude
this little i keep wanting to call them
blast and it's groots
i mean i guess are they blasted screws i
think they're fire crabs
i don't think we even i don't think by
book two we had been introduced
to the blast ended screw just yet okay
now
you know what we need is we need for
these guys
can i like blast him with incendio
no not that way i want to shoot it in
this guy's mouth
oh oh my goodness that's awesome
come on right here you can't even lock
on you just have to
get lucky okay
so i'm still confused as to what the oh
i thought he wasn't going to grab
we've still got that other button that
we've gotta oh no
oh no oh it's timed
oh okay so we gotta hurry all right so
we need to do that one first
all right so let's blast you
all right then blast you
all perfect perfect perfect
come on no glitch no glitch
no glitch
come on no glitch oh it's glitching it's
glitching
there you go nicely done harry all right
so what is this going to turn off
gotcha and i probably have to do the
other one yep
so to get that completely shut off i
have to do this one as well
but now i have to jump back down in
there don't i
so let's see i don't want to lose health
oh okay nice
all right so now i need to go back over
here and i need to push
i guess just that one on the right
or maybe it was the one on the left i'm
going to start with this one
and then i'm going to take the hit from
the fire crab yet again
because that's just how this game is
unfortunately
ha gotcha not this time buddy
all right so now we need to do the same
thing
i probably want to blast this guy first
just to give me a little extra time
oh come on no come on
all right go harry go harry go
oh no but now i can't get over there
ah i was gonna try anyway i cannot take
another hit you guys
oh my goodness i really don't want to
die to this fire crab
all right wait i'm gonna
come on push it no no
push it now
okay does that turn off the one that i
need off
no
i think i'm gonna need this one
yeah i definitely need that one off
because that's the one on the left
okay dude i'm gonna have to go back in
there with the other fire crab though
i really do not want to lose i have to
do all this again man
and i don't think i have any of the
wigan weld potion
unfortunately
hey let's blast you and
quickly press let's see what this one
does
okay yes that's the one i need that's
the one i needed
now let's get out of there quickly
before he can blast us
okay then we need to go to the other
side
shoot those guys the the statues with
incendio
i don't even know what they are they
look like little warthogs to me
what do you guys think warthogs yeah
i think they're war dogs come on no
oh no oh no
we gotta be quick and hope for no
glitches
come on harry big jump
get up there dude i did have wigan weld
let's go dude oh man
saved saved right there guys
that was not gonna be good
oh i would have been so mad
and it wasn't even a glitch i just i
just messed up the jump that time
come on there you go there you go
i really wish there was just a jump
button but hey
they were trying to make it like uh i
think it was
wind waker at the time
that was wait what
i didn't think he was gonna walk i don't
think it was gonna let him go they were
trying to make it sort of similar to the
feel of zelda
you know ocarina of time when wake right
there's no jump button
in those just that auto jump
all right incendio challenge chambers
complete let's go dude
what you got for me flipwick how about
some house points for gryffindor
anything flip cotter yeah
that is all for today class dismissed
class
dismissed just thought i'd remind you
we've got a question another quidditch
match
let's go dude hurry along
let's go quidditch time
oh there's an al homora box right there
dude
now that we've got incendio though
remember we have came across
so many chests throughout this
playthrough where i'm like oh man
oh wait wrong one so many uh chests
where i'm like dude i gotta come back
once we have incendio
a bunch of them with the uh the little
spiderweb
so you used incendio to burn it away all
right let's see what kind of wizard
do we have here zakarisa tugwood
sacharisa tugwood okay interesting we
have yet another
late 1800s wizard card so
she could very well be a lot i mean she
is alive in the late 1800s
and it's possible we could see her in
hogwarts legacy guys pioneer of
beautifying potions discovered pimple
curing properties of bubba tuber
puss okay all right
pimple curing properties guys
pimple curing properties of those bubba
tubers
all right anything else we can do in
here
i think not oh wait wait wait is that
another chest right there
yes it is and i believe yep it is one
where
we need i was i was just talking about
it was i not guys
i was just talking about the ones where
we need to burn away those webs
there we go another wizard card oh man
that i think that takes us to max yep
another health upgrade number 42.
you'd love to see spin cronk crispin
cronk
dude back to back wizard cards
that could come into play for hogwarts
legacy guys uh 1795 to
1872 so
he was pretty old and near his death in
the late 1800s but
he was sent to azkaban for continuing to
keep sphinxes
in his back garden despite repeated
warnings crispin cronk
ladies and gentlemen there you go
all right let's make our way out there
for this quidditch match whoops
although i mean that was two chests in
this room make sure there's not a
third or four
another whizzer card
okay now i've gotta check for a fourth
devlin whitehorn
devlin whitehorn 1945 the present
founder of the nimbus racing broom
company very cool
all right so not a hogwarts legacy
timeline guy but hey
all right dude this like makes me that
one was blending in
so well too that brown and just right
behind
dude i need to go and check behind all
of these in the other classrooms
because i don't know that i've been that
careful when i'm looking around all
right i think that's it there were just
there are three
in there though three wizard cards you
guys we
upgrade our health
and now we're about to go take down
ravenclaw and a quidditch match
but first we must collect a few bertie
ball beans
how about one more okay fine
all right i think there's an incendio
chest down here as well
yep right there it is
another wizard card oh yeah
oh yeah man we're really racking up the
wizard cards now guys
curly duke curly duke 1971 to present
plays lead guitar with the popular
wizarding band the weird sisters
well alrighty then curly duke ladies and
gentlemen
you gotta love the weird sisters all
right let's
uh i guess we could head out to the
entrance hall now
all right back out to the entrance hall
[Music]
let's see our little blue pal oliver
wood not waiting on us this time
i guess he figures we know by now how to
get there
don't worry wood we got you come on
harry
let's show ravenclaw how to play
quidditch let's do it
[Music]
all right i don't want to jinx things
but i think i'm starting to get the hang
of this a little bit
it's still a little uh iffy because
when you use your speed boost
which i'll have here in a second when
you use it it's really hard to keep
going through the rings
you just have to like kind of like make
a burst of speed
going towards the snitch and usually if
you get within the general direction of
it
you'll be fine see i've got the boost
now but i don't want to use it yet
i'm gonna wait till i get a little bit
closer here
oh i missed one
i wonder how long these matches would go
like if i just if i just refuse to catch
the snitch
would ravenclaw eventually catch it and
win
how many points would they score you
know
oh goodness oh my goodness that's just
going straight up
oh no oh dude we are we are down
30 to zero i mean i may find out
if the uh oh and i don't have my speed
boost now i lost it
[Applause]
oh come on make that turn harry there
you go
all right it's about time for that boost
man we got to wait till we get on a
little straight away here
and i don't know if we're going to get
on a away we're going straight up though
[Music]
[Applause]
come on come on come on
oh come on why did not trigger
i was right there
oh dude we're down 40 to 10.
i always thought that you know i love
quidditch man
but the point the point system is
the point system and the structure of
the game
if you can use a little work i'm just
saying
she's about to try and grab it here
let's see if we can get up there
come on there you go potter oh dude look
she is
right behind me
like i just i just i just spam man
like is it ever gonna even fly in my
area
oh my goodness
that is garbage that is garbage that's
what i get for saying like hey i'm
actually getting the hang of it now guys
[Applause]
i have no idea where the snitch is here
it is
angelina johnson's taking a hard hit
there
dude this is our longest quidditch match
yet for sure
70 to 30. so they do they do keep
scoring
no
dude what if we lose
i feel like they they've increased the
difficulty as the games went on because
i don't remember blood just getting
anywhere close to me in other matches
not to mention the other players are
just like
all around me man they're constantly
flying through our rings here
[Applause]
whoa dude
all right come on fred george hit a
bludger her way
ouch
90 to 50 that's not terrible
dude i wonder if you could like set up a
uh
a quidditch world cup scenario could you
could i get
down by enough
could i get down like 160
catch the snitch and lose
oh dude this is ridiculous okay i'm
about to use my boost here
as soon as we get on a little bit of a
straight away come
on
[Applause]
come on potter yes
okay
there we go oh my gosh you guys
invited me that was way too close
gryffindor wins 290. like see like like
the people who were
chasers and uh beaters keepers it's like
all that work you did
eh you know whatever didn't matter
ravenclaw actually way outplayed
gryffindor but
harry got the snitch so gryffindor wins
game over all right we've got two wins
let's move on
what a match indeed just didn't know
what him
anyway i've done about you but i'm worn
out just from cheering
i'm going to bed all right ron good
night buddy
i'm sure hermione's going to have
another task for me to complete oh
there's jess right there you guys
incendio
[Music]
i love how it's just like randomly
sitting behind this rock
another wizard card number 53
greeter catch love greta catch love 1960
to present
author of charm your own cheese
wow i love the random ones like that
like what
did jk rowling sit down and write all of
these for the game or did they
the people who were working on the game
just make some of these out and be like
hey is this cool
can we use this one she's like ah sure
that works
or did she really have all of these
written out
and it's just like this basic author of
charm your own cheese
that's it she needs a wizard card
because
if you write charm your own cheese then
you deserve a wizard card for it
okay guys if you have enjoyed this video
today make sure you give it a thumbs up
before you go i think that's a good
stopping point
next time we'll pick up try to find
trevor uh and then we'll head in
and see what the night will bring thank
you all so much for watching as always
and i'll talk to you again soon